I just knew that I wanted a rap and it
was something was a hobby I just always
kept my mind on focus on the music you
do everything in life for the right
reasons then you always gonna be good I
think it's just growth my thing is just
keeping just like we're moving your ego
out a lot of situations
what's that believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have the ability to do something
special that can change the planet so to
help you on your journey today we're
gonna learn from rapper Tyga and my take
on his top ten rules for success rule
number one is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys
liked the best
I think you know when I was 12 you know
saying like recording in my room like
you know like I didn't know that I was
gonna become a rapper and make a living
off of it or or meet Wayne and get a
chance like I just know I just knew that
I wanted to rap and it was something it
was a hobby and I just really never lost
the faith you know I'm saying like we
don't know where we gonna be at like a
year from now that's what it is this is
like is this knowing but that's what
faith is though right to ability the
ability of belief and things you can't
see or touch I just always kept my mind
on focus on the music good for you man
that's my passion
and that's the that's the talent God
gave me and that's that's what got me to
this point for people to even create
rumors on me you know saying so right
that's always home base for me that's
always the foundation is the music you
got to stay you got to stay focused on
it you know it's not something that's
just for the glitz and glamour or
something that you know you got to
really be passionate about and really
commit to whatever you do anything in
life like if you do things for the wrong
reasons it's gonna come out right bad
you do everything in life for the right
reasons then you always gonna be good
the intention is everything exactly yeah
that's deep though yeah like he's saying
that but it's deep do people do things
for the wrong reasons yeah and you just
sit back and you know you let it play
yourself out I just got to pick and
choose your battles right because I got
in started making music to like be on
reality TV or to like wake up and have
to address TMZ and see stuff in my
lawyer everyday from TMZ and it's like I
don't care about that like yeah you know
that means so I think you just got to
really know you know how to pick and
choose your battles and stay focused on
what your vision is and where your goal
or you're trying to get to Kanye you're
like yo I need my cash money a milli a
milli a milli are you are you still
chasing that or are you just kind of
moving on are you moving on from that
now we just on a new wave like no way
but it's money though
you feel me like your money isn't it's
more money though in fact if I could do
it once I could do it twice if I could
do it twice it's not the wave is that
the vibe feel me like if I could make
one hey I can make two I don't think you
I could make ten mm-hmm you know I'm
saying I feel like God put me in this
position to uplift other people who move
forward you know I'm saying like I don't
really dwell on the past but at the same
time like I'm letting people know like
I'm a businessman at the end of the day
and this is you know you gotta treat
people right you know many people put in
work you got to take care of them you
got to take care of people because at
the end of the day we can't take it when
we leave so amen now what's going on
with lightweight cash money Young Money
are you still affiliated light in a
major way are you kind of tiger now
I mean um I'm just I'm just pushing my
brand and that's what I've been tired
and so I don't really like I don't
really rely on them for anything right
you know like I always built my brand
from ground up so you ain't playing when
you talk about your brand brother yeah
everything you wearing is yours he got
his own gold line out man yeah you got
blood diamonds that gold bar yeah yeah
and I brought some it's my new water
right don't do this to me man soda in
the schools and stuff like that so this
is like natural fruit water only 30
calories is this your own water for real
is it busy like sodas sparkling water
yeah so it's like not just bland yes it
still kind of tastes like soda a little
bit but yes dude came in with his own
war
there's no alcohol in here right he do I
just took a smell good as you know drink
is down not gonna like grow tattoos and
it's not energy water at all right okay
so Oh energy well here I don't I won't
keep it real with you it tastes like you
woulda brought it in of you knows right
now it's good we got different flavors
you gotta talk to me man clothing line
tennis shoes you walk in here with
energy and water shoes tennis shoes you
know Sam right yeah you do make music
too right yeah that's awesome I mean
that's where I started you know it was
funny like I always wanted to do like
action and like horror stuff yeah you
know so that was for that to be like my
first row shout-out to Ferrell for
putting me in that know it was funny so
you know it's just something that I
wanted to really take serious cuz I I
got offered a lot of movie roles before
oh wow like I had I offered to be on
Empire like you didn't do Empire it was
no because I was like you got a thing
like when people sell this stuff like
you know if you heard of the Maze Runner
yeah movies I was supposed to be in it
it was a lot of movies up but I just
wasn't focused and I wasn't where I
wanted to be in my life to where I just
wanted to to act okay I mean I felt like
I'm not gonna take on something if I
can't be a hundred percent fully
invested in it I know so I feel like now
is the right time they do the right the
right roles how do you get to this
headspace pause how do you get to the
headspace with the head and pause and
pause what is it is it is it meditation
is it weed what do we do is the
conversations with your mother I think
it's just growth me I think is just
keeping just like removing your ego out
a lot of situations you know I've heard
that I've heard
like remove the ego yeah cause it's like
it's a time and place for everything and
I'm saying when I'm on that stage I'm
full ego doubt because that's class
place of comfort that's my place of like
this is my this is my house I think is
just something that's been gone for like
the last couple of years
okay like even in the studio with him
like when he was working on his islands
when he was working on users and you
know I'm saying I was like that just in
the studio and just being around and I
think being a just me as a person
you know I'm saying more than anything
and it just he just watched my vision he
just knows my vision and you know I mean
he's somebody that I I definitely value
what he says you know his vision cuz
it's a second genius like me you don't
meet something people like that like
they give you that type of feeling like
Pharrell is another person that's like a
genius to me like Wayne lyrically you
know I'm saying it's like a couple
people that I really like I love lies
that are still living you know I'm
saying president now that's like that
give that feeling and then you know I
didn't never it was never in my like my
plan of my I like to be like they don't
want to sign the kind one day like like
I was in my room making mixtapes listen
in the way mixtapes like man like I want
to rap Wayne like that was my goal and
it happened you know I'm saying like he
just came into fruition but that's what
somebody I was like man like be from any
squad I want to wrap a wing or like be
from like Star Trek because I used to
love like the clips I listen to audition
you know I'm saying so like that was
like my two homes that I felt like I
either Pharrell I like when the learning
is never over you know I'm saying like
as much stuff as I learned being around
Wayne it's different the things I
learned around Chi and the things I
learned a run away and I wouldn't have
learned along cayenne the things I learn
come out when they learn from Wayne
[Applause]
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because silex be the
brain box ask me to if there's someone
you'd like to vote on for the next top
ten check out the link in the
description and go and have your say
finally I wanted to give a quick chatter
to VJ Raj VJ thank you so much for
picking up a cup of my book your one
word and doing those three videos on
your channel I really appreciate the
support man and I'm so glad that you
enjoyed the book making you feel
uncomfortable because they want to do
something that's not outlined but your
one word is not so make sure you choose
wisely so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love
we'll see you soon
[Music]
I just always had a passion for some and
I've always been able to focus on one
thing so I don't really know how it
feels to hate on somebody else or just
worry about what somebody else is doing
cuz I'm so focused on my vision right so
I think for a lot of people it's like
you got to just kind of find a vision
right you know you see everybody's
entitled to their own opinion you know
for sure but it's just some things you
gotta just you just gotta be wise about
and just more rational I'm still human
you know I'm saying
I still have real problem just like
everybody else you know and you always
want to be able to relate to people
because when you got it when you got
millions of people around the world
looking up to you and you know dressing
like you're talking like right right
getting tattoos like you yeah whatever
whatever whatever whatever in cases you
know I mean you got to know that you got
it's bigger than just you and the people
around you like you actually have
influence on a lot of people in the
world isn't that crazy it is you know
it's a lot of it's a lot of
responsibility what do you think I don't
think it's a lot of responsibility but
at the end the day you I feel like
knowing knowing that a lot of people
follow me and and look to everything I
do everything every day it makes me just
it makes me more proud of myself knowing
that I'm that I'm doing the right thing
by them or you know and uh just
influencing them you know me like I'm
not like I'm not promoting like
negativity I'm not promoting like super
dumb violence I'm not saying like go
kill you so I'm not saying no like you
know I'm saying like I'm promoting like
I'm promoting god I'm promoting healthy
living I'm promoting better living
promoting you know I'm saying oh right
it wasn't me it was in the right place I
always been it's the heart it's always
been in my heart at the end of the day
it's night like I came in the game when
I was 17 18 I saw him away when I was 18
very young I'm coming from a place to
where like like you said like not
knowing anything dropping out of high
school you know working at the mall to
like being on tour with like the the
next biggest rapper in the world
I was like I wasn't focused on the
mission as far as like you know trying
to influence other people I was just
like in the moment and I was just fanned
out so you know when the smoke clears
and I was able to kind of like see his
Drive and his passion apply that to what
I was doing yeah you know and then
actually get success and actually see
success off of it like wow this really
sure you know this is this could really
work you know and then and then then I
felt like having it taken away from me
in a way towards like I put in all this
hard work people crown me and then it's
almost like they wanted to stone me you
know I'm saying so they're not that was
like I wouldn't say that's not what it
felt like but it definitely it seemed
that way it seemed that way it was like
when it's like yo like I've always been
this great person I've always been
promoting positive and like just mind my
own business
everybody knows like heard of the blogs
and stuff you know I just wanted to make
a record kind of I was kind of like more
inspiring and motivational you know
saying because like I feel like you know
that blog you know always attacks me all
the time you know but I didn't but see
I'm not a petty person no you don't
sound do things like I said I despite
all I got anger nothing like that and
then like I had the concept already we
had the concept already in my hand I was
like hey I really want to take this but
make it like relevant